one thing is obvious Israel
for
decades if it had wanted to perpetrate a
genocide against the Palestinians could
have done that on any given day right it
would have been trivia tomorrow they
could kill everyone in Gaza if they
wanted they obviously haven't wanted
that they obviously don't want to do
that now if you reverse that balance of
power and ask what would Hamas do what
would jihadist
organizations anywhere do uh
they would kill all the Jews and they
and they have told us that ad nauseum
the founding Charter of Hamas said that
explicitly it look forward to a time
where where konic prophecy would be
realized when the Earth itself would cry
out against the Jews where where the the
rocks and the trees would say oh Muslim
there's a Jew behind me come kill him
right except for one tree yeah except
the one tree yes yeah that's right um so
that the the difference in intention
while people think
intention is this is this um abstraction
intention is the software that everyone
is running inent intention is the best
predictor of what people will do if
they're given an opportunity to do it
right if they have the power to do it if
they have the technology to do it um
what will a jihadist organization do if
it gets nuclear weapons what will a
jihadist organization do if it
gets you know a a viable bioweapon right
we know the answers to these questions
these people have been telling us this
for as long as I've been alive and and
and and in isolated cases absolutely
proven to a moral certainty their
commitment to nihilism and Massacre I
mean the the Islamic State if if if you
couldn't if you knew the details of what
was happening in the Islamic State and
couldn't understand that these people
mean what they say and believe what they
say they believe then you're you're
living on another planet so anyone who's
surprised the only surprise here is
that there was an assumption and you
know historically understandable
assumption that Hamas was not as Extreme
as Al-Qaeda or the Islamic State uh and
it certainly seems that some among them
are prepared to be that extreme so we
just have to acknowledge that there is a
subset of people in the Muslim world who
for whom it is true as they say of
themselves
that they love death more than we love
life we being free secular people
everywhere Jews Christians M moderate
Muslims uh the there are people who
actually want to be martyred and have
their and see their kids martyred right
this is not they're not
bluffing they're they're perfectly
willing to die for the pleasure and
and um opportunity of killing non
combatants intentionally killing
non-combatants so that the moral error
that people are going to make now and
they they've they're already making it
is to think that when Israel tells
people to evacuate Northern Gaza and
they don't because Hamas is telling them
not to do it or it becomes practically
impossible and Egypt doesn't let them
out Etc um and they drop bombs
targeting uh Hamas installations that
have been purposefully put next to
civilian areas that will cause Carnage
when when Israel bombs them like
hospitals and schools and mosques when
Israel bombs those targets and kids die
which is obviously horrible that is the
same thing
as Hamas jihadists coming in under cover
of Rocket fire at dawn and murdering
babies in their cribs it's not the same
thing and that disparity is um as far as
the the moral you know algebra that that
can give you insight into the difference
between the two sides that disparity
says everything to me it's like you know
this is something I recently said in my
own podcast but if you just imagine the
Israelis attempting to use their own
non-combatants as human Shields right in
any conflict against jihadist you let's
say Hezbollah comes across the northern
border and the Israelis line up with
their own women and kids you know
putting the barrels of of their weapons
on the on the shoulders of their
children thinking that Hezbollah is
going to be reluctant to shoot through
the bodies of their children to kill is
IDF
soldiers I mean it is a completely
surreal you know Monty Python sketch
where all the Jews die it is not it it
is laughable it is Unthinkable it's
Unthinkable at every level of it it's
Unthinkable that the that the Jews would
treat their own children and and and
non-combatants that way given what they
believe about everything and it's not
Unthinkable that they would think that
their enemies would be deterred by that
behavior right but when you reverse it
as it is the case in in the real
world we have had to conf we all we
westerners and the Israelis have had to
confront this behavior on multiple
fronts in every conflict against
jihadists they routinely use
non-combatants as human Shields and and
Hamas is doing that now um I think
Israel has to figure out how to navigate
around that and
eradicate jihadists you know eradicate H
we're we're confounded to some degree by
our terminology here we keep talking
about terrorists and we we we had a war
on terror for you know the quarter of a
century now
um terrorism is a tactic terrorism is
not the thing we're fighting we're
fighting Jihad and um what's the
difference Sam explain to people what
the difference is well jihadism jihadism
is the
the the
um the radical core of Islam it is this
is this principle of holy war that can
be justified in various contexts yes
there are many many millions of Muslims
thankfully who just who would justify it
in in ways that we would recognize as
something we could live with right so a
defensive War right a just War just War
Theory okay great there are other
Muslims who say no no no you don't
understand J is just an inner spiritual
struggle okay great but historically and
practically now Jihad has all a
component of jihad has always been you
you convert subjugate kill the Infidel
right it's like the Islam Islam is a
religion of Conquest it views itself as
a religion of Conquest it it expects to
win these these these contests for
believers at the you know at the end of
time and it has an exp
explicitly uh
martial ethic which
is
uh we have to win through Force right
and we're happy to Die Trying all
however long we fail we're ultimately
going to Su succeed but we're happy to
throw our our bodies and the bodies of
our children into this because this life
is a total illusion it is has Absol
absolutely no value this is just a a
anti- room on the on the thresholds of
either heaven or hell and the only thing
that matters is where you go after you
die right and only the True Believers uh
go go to paradise and um if you kill
them inadvertently if you blow up a
crowd of K of Muslim kids in an attempt
to kill some soldiers that are handing
out candy to them as happened in our
conflict in Iraq and Afghanistan um
there is no Factor the kids the the good
Muslims the real Muslims are going to
Paradise they're going to thank you
right no problem um and the bad Muslims
the fake Muslims the the infidels the
the the
idolators they're going to go to hell
sooner and that's good that's an
intrinsic good that's exactly what the
creator of the universe wants um there
it's impossible to make a moral error
when you're a jihadist right if you die
it's good if your family dies it's good
if the Infidel dies it's good this is a
death cult and we have been lying to
ourselves you in the secular West that's
there's some other logic some other
variable that explains this Behavior
it's economics it's politics these are
the assumption is that when you see
people behaving in this extraordinarily
destructive and you know Psychopathic
way they must have been pushed there by
some awful treatment that would explain
it right this must be ordinary human
rational behavior in extremis right
these people have been so tortured by
the occupation by the the apartheid
state of of Israel by the open air
prison of Gaza I mean these these
phrases that are now you know used
reflexively in the media I'm not saying
I'm not saying life in Gaza isn't
horrible I'm not saying it's not
intolerable we can talk about that but
there's a layer of this phenomenon and
this behavior that we've been living
with uh you know most clearly since
September 11 2001 but it obviously
precedes
that which is is explained only by the
religious ideology right what the when
people are doing the
unthinkable
uh again you can find so many cases
where they're doing it without grievance
right where somebody drops out of the
London School of Economics to go join
the Islamic State for the pleasure of
killing yazidis and you know raping
their women right it's just this is and
this is this was
happening you know ad nauseum right you
had from a 100 countries right so this
is so what we saw Hamas do in Israel
last
week is a subset it's just another
example of that same behavior yes it has
this local political
nationalistic uh struggle over territory
context but that's not the thing that
explains the
behavior